[Musique]
bonjour monsieur monsieur roux
très bien et ben alexander a enfanté
avec sandra je voudrais qu'on écoute
eric zemmour il était hier chez nos
confrères de lci avec ruth elkrief je
vous propose d'écouter ce qu'il a dit la
cité du général de gaulle sur pourra
vous seriez je vais cesser comme les
salles et restaurants où il avait
rendu la pomme de terre en entrée pommes
de terre au plat de résistance la place
bessières pommes de terre et après
pousse café avec des quelques pommes de
terre j'étais à votre émission
d'ailleurs tu indiques tu as quelque
chose ou dépendants de quelque chose à
toi non me dit
je suis assez d'accord avec vous mais
on a une aide effective oui mais je suis
assez d'accord yahia discussion
ce que je dis non mais lâché domenech
fait d'accord je suis d'accord mais ça
me pose un problème d'ailleurs laissé
comme le co vie d'un moment je parlais
que kovy moi je parle des sujets qui
intéressent les gens je veux bien parler
des sujets qui intéressent pas des gens
mais bon ça intéresse manifestera jusque
là et là on vous dirait de voir la photo
d'une poubelle par exemple la poubelle
de mick jagger au dessus de la cheminée
par exemple si enfin l'odeur zaragoza ça
tombe bien ça tombe bien puisque c'est
que des des photos parce que vous avez
les poubelles de star des photographes
pascal rosstat et bruno mouron ils ont
fasciné le monde entier ça fait le tour
du monde des expositions et à quatre
photos de poubelles de stars sont vente
aujourd'hui à drum poubelle la vie à
marseille les éboueurs travail entre 3h
et 3h30 par jour selon un rapport de la
chambre régionale des comptes la
métropole aix en provence a décidé de
les faire travailler davantage pour un
salaire inchangé à partir de janvier les
éboueurs devrait travailler deux heures
de plus par jour pour se mettre en
conformité avec la loi est aussi simple
que ça
tous les élus et encore moins
qu'aujourd'hui absolument parce
qu'aujourd'hui alors année absolument
mais si je vous invite tous donc c'est
sûr vous avez des grandes puissances
puisque vous avez des grandes gueules
vous avez tous allés à la bête est
aimanté derrière une benne l'estimation
a pour ses photos de poubelles c'est
entre 14 milles
et c'est plus de 16000 euros donc voilà
c'est l'oeuvre d'art c'est décidé c'est
vrai dire c'est qu'en fait c'est comme
des natures mortes tout simplement sur
des oeuvres d'art comme les autres et
poubelles eh oui si vous décidez de
parler de culture c'est parce qu'elle
est singulièrement absente de tous les
discours que l'on peut attendre à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
et c'est même pire non seulement on n'en
parle pas mais quand on en parle c'est
pour haïr
les grands principes de la civilisation
qui est la nôtre nous sommes sommés de
nous des blanchir de nous
désaisonnalisées molière moi je connais
pas parce qu'en italie on n'étudie pas
la littérature française un gars super
16e et ses patients molière pour le
cheval à l'école attendre de quelqu'un
c'est pas allons-y fouillons là mais on
va fouiller la poubelle 2010 gaza que
c'est incroyable c'est ce que tu sais ce
que tu disais c'est impossible de
deviner que c'est mick jagger regard des
faits son propre pain ça c est quand
même incroyable c'est insoupçonnable il
pas du tout rock'n'roll c'est quoi elle
colle sans fumée sans alcool
je vois way sans fumée sans alcool quand
je vois certaines têtes je me demandais
je veux
l'alcool les français champions du monde
il figure parmi les plus gros
consommateurs il y aurait 4 millions
d'alcooliques mondain france à en
théorie il ne faudrait pas boire plus de
deux verres par jour et pourtant à quoi
voyez vous que votre conjoint a bu un
verre de trop belles vomi
aujourd'hui ce que tu as ta peur tous
les jours on canton mais c'est vrai tu
dis voilà il faut que je profite à fond
dedans mon papa est ce côté ça coule de
source quoi ouais c'est ça sur ce
question rhétorique évidemment je te
sens peu énervé toi cher c'est vrai ces
salles pour la vie de la famille tapie
alors que celle ci se soit stéphane est
ce encore mais on peut s'en fout on peut
s'en [__] plein la gueule il est
content d'être avec nous m comment parce
que nous on le traite bien parce que
vous verriez les autres avocats ce
qu'ils disent de me d'ailleurs expliquer
ce que l'on dit de vous je suis un amant
bonjour parce que alors que nous
donnerons pas là d'or ça ne regarde
personne chacun a le droit d'avoir sa
vie m de montmoreau pas pourquoi les
gens du barreau vous hisser enfin peu
importe si t'es pas content d'être là tu
peux gagner ma sofina moi je t'aime
beaucoup n'ont jamais c'est bon parce
qu'à un moment un moment c'est bon tu
vois j'ai été sympa je t'aime beaucoup
j'ai été sympa avec toute la famille
tout le temps là un moment c'est vrai
que j'aime beaucoup bernard tapie mais à
un moment il faut avoir aussi un petit
peu de respect pour nos téléspectateurs
mais c'est hyper ému nous
je suis ému mais je ne rajoutez pas on a
l'impression de te faire chier mais si
on te fait chier c'est l'inversé c'est
son nom mais je suis très très mal à
l'aise alors il ya monsieur en plus
c'est marrant aussi à capital non non
c'est pas ça il ya monsieur sur twitter
savez vous pouvez réagir sur le hashtag
cpv à qui vient d'écrire que j'incarnais
la lourdeur même il a pas tout à fait
tort
la maintenance est de faire cette blague
je me suis dit tiens ce monsieur n'est
pas complètement à côté de la plaque non
plus est ce que je regarde mon téléphone
juste après le réveil
non seulement quand je vais aux
toilettes
oui d'accord après être allé aux
ok très bien parfait
donc tous bien qu'en retrait immédiat
fait
parfois j'ai même pas le temps de sortir
du livre il ya quelques mois l'arrivée
sur le pq ouais ben rubin oui oui comme
ça est totalement injustifiée autant
cette fois il y à de vraies raisons de
s'inquiéter parmi les signaux d'alert
elle cet avertissement lancé par et city
et city c'est le groupe qui exploite la
marque lotus pour le papier toilette
mais qui fabrique aussi les essuie-tout
hockey ou encore les les serviettes
hygiéniques nana la direction a prévenu
les coûts de production il flambe et +30
% en seulement quelques mois c'était pas
une odeur
c'est
pas mon chien
si ces perles elle pas bien son nom
c'était quelque chose qui rend un chien
est un homme heureux à vos buzzer
à manger
mon chèque rocket man gmail et
sa vallée de voile à l'achat de
croquettes
j'en
appelle à nos moutons à saran bouton
qu'on compte tarot et quoi de l'orang
outan ou je sais pas quoi autant orangs
outans jeu puis un truc dans ce délire
influent qui se mange en tout cas ça se
mange peu importe le nom moi je fais le
démonter
moi j'avais un athlète qui était que
tard au pluriel bah oui c'est tellement
fait admis abbas est admis oui regardez
la réponse à la dernière réponse qu'on
cherchait qu est-ce que c'était
en août et en levant avec les chiens